the ambulance and its crew have been on
the road for less than an hour and Gigi
and John are already responding to their
third emergency it's a category two an
elderly patient they got a special alarm
that they compress but sometimes when
it's in the they get a call in the
morning because their care has found
them on the floor but they've been there
all night basically and they said that
this has been there since nine o'clock
last night
pretty long time Gigi and John have to
be prepared for anything hello
oh hello
it's the ambulance okay they see and
treat the most vulnerable in society in
their most desperate moments did you
press your button today yes yes and what
did you need the ambulance for because I
could I followed it out of my bed oh
okay I couldn't get up I see Elizabeth
is 78. she spends most of her life in
this room I've had knee replacement yeah
hip replacement okay I've got plantar
fasciitis in both feet oh okay and my
sciatic nerve is trapped ouch so you're
in pain oh dear yeah a quarter of
non-life-threatening 999 calls last
winter involved fools what are you
struggling with at the minute
uh
get into my bed at night sure okay like
I couldn't get out of the bed this
morning
Elizabeth has a carer who visits three
times a day
it's not enough how often do you fall
twice a day twice a day so quite often
patients like Elizabeth are more
vulnerable than ever this winter they
face a potential rise in flu and covert
cases ambulance response times at an
all-time high and a care system short of
some 165
000 staff
um do you want us to bring you anything
before we leave
thousand pounds only a thousand pounds
I've gone ten thousand pounds
what have you got him no I don't know
all right all the best Elizabeth okay it
looks like she's had quite a few
ambulances maybe probably about 200 in
the last year if there was a carer there
help her out of bed every time get her
some food and this is what happens a lot
is if when there's no carers coming in
they tend to fall over because they need
to do everything themselves some 55 000
ambulance trips are made every year to
people who have fallen but don't require
Hospital treatments
so now rapid response teams are being
created to ease the pressure on a
struggling system
it's all part of the nhs's preparations
for winter one which many think will be
its toughest yet
Josh is Sky News